Is there anything more satisfying in CS:GO that landing a crisp, clean bullet to the dome?
Well... maybe getting out of Silver,
I wouldn’t know.
I’m Colin for theScore esports and this week on Top 10 we're talking all about headshots baby.
Now, there's been six years of competitive CS:GO.
That's six years of melon-melting, armor-piercing headshots.
And picking the 10 of those was nearly impossible.
But we did it anyway. So from to pistols to AWPs, wallbangs to one-taps,
here are the Top 10 Headsho- f--k
here are the Top 10 Headshots in CS:GO
The first play on our list is a historic ace from EnvyUs’ Happy at Dreamhack Open London 2015.
After four beautiful headshots, and one slightly less beautiful kill, later Happy  earned
himself a permanent spot in CS GO history.
(Casting)
Coming in at number 9 is the, now infamous, Bodyy wallbangs against Astralis during ESL Proleague S5.
Bodyy manages to hit not one but two headshots, through the wall, from spawn, in one map.
Shots so insane that Valve actually had to patch them out of the game.
(Casting)
The number 8 play on our list puts the spotlight on Fnatic’s olofmeister, who absolutely
dismantled NA’VI in a 1v5 at ESL One Katowice 2015.
Oh yeah, and he did it with four back-to-back Tec 9 Headshots.
(Casting)
At number 7 is a creative play from NiP’s GeT_RiGhT in the losers bracket final of StarSeries season 12.
Getting a boost from allu, GeT_RiGhT hits an absolutely disgusting mid air headshot
with the Tec 9 on Device...
that just shouldn't be possible.
(Casting)
Back at it again at number 6 is GeT_RiGhT, this time at the ESL Proleague Season 4 semifinals.
GeT_RiGhT shows off his laser focus with this near instant flick onto Fer.
Hitting this wallbang headshot with the narrowest of margins.
(Casting)
Coming in at number 5 is a play that comes from Dreamhack Open Cluj 2015’s closed qualifier.
Adren managed to secure this insane 4k clutch to win this round against Wizards with the
final kill coming from a VAC-worthy 180 degree flick to some poor soul’s face.
(Casting)
ScreaM is a name synonymous with one taps.
In our number 4 play from CS Summit 2017 he didn’t even have the luxury of the second
chance but still managed to connect his lone AK bullet with Fer’s melon.
(Casting)
One headshot is nice.
Two is impressive.
Three is nearly super-human.
But four? What in God’s name is this play from Snax.
(Casting)
How do you top 4 back-to-back headshots?
Well, try five, with our runner up play from EnvyUs’ XMS at the PGL Europe Minor Championship 2017.
XMS melts all five members of Team Kinguin with only five bullets.
(Casting)
Taking the top spot on our list is a play that has etched itself in CS:GO history.
We’ve all seen it a million times and it ages like a fine wine.
So sit back and watch in awe at Hiko’s still inhuman reaction.
(Casting)
Well guys that’s our list for this week.
Now if you do disagree with it, I advise to load up an aim and practice your head shots.
Don’t even comment, don’t @ me.
I don’t want to hear it,
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.